allez on passe à notre second débat
débat de société qui est volontairement
vous le savez décalée de l'actualité du
jour il est consacré ce soir l'écriture
1 tu inclusif pardon faut-il triturer la
langue je reprends et c'est pas la
première fois dans cette émission
l'expression du ministre de l'éducation
la question se pose de nouveau après la
décision du dictionnaire le robert
d'intégrer dans sa version numérique le
pronom yale reportage de lien est fait
avec des sénateurs divisée
elle est quasiment inutilisé et pourtant
la formule yale suscite le débat ces
trois lettres les adeptes de l'écriture
inclusive aimerait les voir devenir un
nouveau pronom personnel contraction de
ils et elles le mot désigne une personne
sans distinction de genre une polémique
est née lorsque le dictionnaire robert
décide de l'intégrer à son édition en
ligne le mois dernier au sénat les
parlementaires sont majoritairement
contre cette pseudo modernité qui
consiste à proposer des trucs que je
trouve un peu saugrenue
dépassement quotient intellectuel
et magath si on arrêtait le ridicule
dans ce pays ça ferait pas de mal ainsi
on s'occuper des vrais problèmes des
gens yelle qui va comprendre ce que ça
veut dire est vraiment mais à volonté
d'utiliser cette contraction
ne me choque pas du tout je pense que la
langue lgi avec une société et les
crispations identitaires en la matière
n'ont pas lieu d'être moi je comprends
pas l'écriture inclusive j'arrive pas
l'écrire j'arrive pas la lire depuis
2010 est l'écriture inclusive est
interdite dans l'ensemble des actes
administratifs
il y a 6 mois cette mesure est élargi à
l'école une circulaire banni l'usagé du
point médian des enseignements scolaires
à cette occasion un débat houleux a
opposé les sénateurs il au pari
dangereux de sacrifier l'apprentissage
de l'écriture et de la lecture sur
l'autel de l'instrumentalisation
d'autres langues à des fins idéologiques
les féministes du moment sont toujours
radicales et excessives et les bonnes
féministe celles qui ont eu raison c'est
celle d'avant eh bien écoutez bonne
croisade bonne bataille pendant ce temps
là la langue évolue
l'académie française alerte elle d'un
danger de péril mortel pour la langue
française face à la diffusion de
l'écriture inclusive et je vous présente
mes invités éliane viennot bonsoir bien
vous êtes professeur émérite de
littérature de la renaissance
historienne des relations de pouvoir
entre les sexes ou publié en finir avec
l'homme chronique d'une imposture 7 aux
éditions x lille à braunschweig bonjour
bienvenue vous êtes chercheuse en
théorie politique vous publiez ne trees
et émancipation au pluriel par le neutre
dans la collection trans aux éditions
les liens qui libèrent brice couturier
bonsoir soir vous êtes journaliste
essayiste votre livre c'est ok millénium
seul en quête d'un baby boomer sur les
beats de la génération ou hawks échec l
éditeur déjà c'est à l'observatoire à
l'observatoire merci j'avais pas
d'informations avec nos en
visioconférence olivier paccaud ancien
enseignant sénateur
de l'oise rattaché au groupe lr bonsoir
à vous aussi matthieu croissandeau et ce
jour à mes côtés évidemment alors on va
élargir le nôtre débat la question de
l'écriture inclusive de l'évolution de
la langue de ce que la langue dit d'une
société évidemment on a on a quarante
minutes pour le faire mais quand même
votre point de vue sur cette décision du
robert en ligne fallait-il intégré yale
ce pronom personnel je commence avec
vous il ya de gênant mais je crois que
le robert ait fait son travail
comme d'autres dictionnaires qui chaque
année intègrent entre 20 et 30 mots
nouveaux oui on enlève autant à peu près
et donc voilà pour moi c'est une cette
polémique là la discussion sur est ce
que leur père avait raison de le faire
ou de ne pas le faire c'est une
polémique complètement artificielle
pourquoi et comment vous réagissez au
fait que le robert et et pris cette
décision vous dites qu'il ya autre chose
qu'une polémique artificielle il ya des
symboles derrière via les entend dire je
vous ai entendu quand on essaie
d'attenté à la langue et la
tripatouiller c'est qu'on a des arrière
pensées se se prononcent nouveau ce
néo-pro non comme on dit en anglais adam
n'est d'aucun usage je vous ce que vous
avez déjà entendu quelqu'un auprès de
vous parler de quelqu'un d'autre en dix
ans et yale non bien entendu donc c'est
imposer un nom un mot nouveau un public
qui n'en peut pas normalement le rôle de
l'actionnaire c'est d'enregistrer les
usages pas de lait forget pas de les
imposer lors c'est ça qui est derrière
bien on me dit que quoi c'est une
décision presque ses logiciels a bien
entendu ça veut dire qu'il ya une
offensive au hockey dans les médias
français dans l'édition française dans
l'université française
elle vise les hauts qui sont persuadés
que la langue et le véhicule principal
de l'idéologie et de la domination
puisqu'ils cherchent la domination et le
pouvoir par tous par conséquent ça fait
longtemps qu'ils avaient la langue en
vue il attaquait la langue parce
qu'elles étaient leurs réserves art
d'une idéologie qu'ils détestent là ils
essaient de cesser pour un marxiste est
extraordinaire c'est un extrait
renversement l'idée qu'une super
structures comme la langue puisse
transformer la société ca les rapports
de production ça montre que ces gens
sont des idéalistes fou des marxistes
avait compris depuis longtemps que c'est
le contraire qui se passe que c'est les
rapports de production qui détermine les
superstructures et non l'inversé assure
d'avoir en face de moi des idéalistes
folle mais j'aimerais entendre votre
réaction il me semble que contrairement
je crois à ce que vous dites il y à un
usage du pronom yale peut-être que pas
forcément autour de vous mais si le
robert a pris la peine de l'insérer
c'est il me semble pour répondre oui à
un usage de personnes qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans la binarité
hommes femmes et qui ont qui ont besoin
en fait demain nouveau prenons parce que
les pronoms il est elle donc la
troisième personne du singulier du
pluriel en français ne donnent pas cette
opportunité là de se reconnaître au delà
de la binarité et moi je connais des
gens qui l'utilisent donc peut-être une
distinction
elle est présentée à tout le monde parce
qu'on les cherche à fait plus de dix ans
que
jamais entendu oui non mais c'est mon
personnel comme le dit le robert c'est
un usage raoui mais tous les maux qui
sont intégrés nouvellement dans un
dictionnaire sont forcément rare puisque
sinon il aurait été un tueur les gens
les aiment c'est dans les bourgs doivent
entendre ce qui fonde la lexicographie
on remarquait que sais tu ce pronom est
utilisé depuis au moins une dizaine
d'années olivier pas que vous nous
écoutez en visioconférence est
évidemment voulait réagir on reste pour
l'instant sur ce pronom yale et puis
ensuite on élargira le débat encore
écouter sur le pronom yale je vais être
franc avec vous reçoivent 2 à 300 mails
par jour et une dizaine de courriers et
bien pour être très franc j'ai reçu mon
premier courrier avec le moyenne
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'était
l'invitation d'une commune qui s'appelle
le mesnil théribus pour une soirée
festive
donc je dois être déconnecté de la
réalité certaine certains mais très
honnêtement je ne connais personne
autour de moi qui utilise se prononce
quant à l'écriture inclusive très
objectivement elle me semble là aussi
hors du champ du quotidien de l'immense
majorité des gens le but de l'écriture
comme de tout mode de communication
c'est de communiquer le but de
l'écriture inclusif ce n'est pas de
communiquer le but de l'écriture
inclusive c'est d'affirmer une cause de
combattre pour une cause qui est fort
noble qui est l'égalité hommes femmes
mais à mon avis il ya une divergence de
fonction et l'écriture inclusive se
plante totalement je suis issue je suis
élu d'un canton qui quitteraient
prolétaires entre guillemets personnes
je vous dis bien personne n'utilise
l'écriture inclusive le bon sens ce
n'est pas l'ex futur inclusive et je ne
connais aucune maîtresse ou aucun
enseignant encore préparatoire qui
souhaiteraient planter ou plonger sa
plume dans l'encrier de l'écriture
inclusive bon goût à ses élèves à lui
prendra la parole tout à l'heure par don
d interrompre les olivier paccaud je
sais pas si vous allez être l' arbitre
de ce débat on a peut-être que ça sur le
pont long biên en tout cas moi je pense
qu'une langue c'est une matière vivante
donc qui sortait des dons qui rentrait
des noms qui se réinvente et de ce point
de vue là je défends pas une langue
figée
et qu'un nom comme yell rentrer dans les
actionnaires ça ne me choque pas un d un
dictionnaire c'est précisément plein de
noms compliqués dont on connaît pas la
signification il est fait pour ça après
se pose la question des usages c'est ce
qui distingue les langues vivantes des
langues mortes c'est une langue vivante
c'est une langue où il se passe quelque
chose est ce que ce terme est usité
comme on dit dans les dictionnaires ou
peu usité est ce que il sera cesser
l'usagé on verra si l'uci c'est celle
usages qui en fera un nom légitime entre
guillemets ou non mais il a sa place
dans le dictionnaire parti au moment où
même si certains utilisent un
dictionnaire c'est quand même plein de
mots compliqués dont on connaît pas la
signification encore une fois mais il
faut pas être complètement naïf non plus
c'est vrai qu'il ya une volonté
politique derrière de politique au sens
noble du terme c'est l'état de vouloir
affirmer un combat unis saisie des dents
assez c est dans la cité et que ce
pronom là il est le produit de sa de des
gens comme vous l'avez dit qu'ils se
reconnaissent pas dans la binarité et
qui en font une revendication c'est à
dire qu'ils seront n'existe pas dans la
langue donc on n'existe pas dans la
société en gros si je si je caricature
un peu or on veut exister donc il ya une
volonté d'affirmation alors votre
réaction à l'argument d'olivier paco sur
le fait de peut-être complexifier la
longue inutilement alors mon problème
mon problème général dans ce débat c'est
que la plupart des gens qui parlent de
l'écriture inclusive ne savent pas de
compte par là moi personnellement j'ai
écrit des livres entiers depuis des
années en écriture égalitaire qu'on peut
appeler non sexiste qu'on peut appeler
non discriminante qu'on peut appeler
inclusif et des grands éditeurs les plus
grands éditeurs les accepte quand on
parle d'art et d'une écriture accusés
c'est peut-être le point médian c'est
c'est vraiment
à dire linz dans les français parlent
aux français dans le dans le
programme si je puis dire de nous
débarrasser d'eux des usages sexiste de
notre langue et bien c'est rien du tout
ce n'est qu une abréviation le point
médian c'est une abréviation qui a été
proposée après plusieurs autres pour
remplacer les parenthèses le entre
parenthèses parce que dans un pays qui
se veut égalitaire
on met la marque du féminin entre
parenthèses ce n'est pas correct un bon
parce qu'on met entre parenthèses dans
un discours c'est ça n'a pas le même
statut que ce qu'on met hors de la
parenthèse donc on cherche depuis 10 ans
20 ans 30 ans remplacée cet usage de la
parenthèse qui n'a pas été inventé par
les féministes mais par le ministère de
l'intérieur sans doute dans les années
60 voyez cette parenthèse donc et par
ailleurs on n'est jamais obligée de
faire des abréviations voyant on peut
écrire les français et les françaises en
toutes lettres de même qu'on peut écrire
monsieur en toutes lettres et poèmes
points donc le débat s'est focalisé la
place également abandonné ce point
médian qui eux mais non il est très
utile dans certains usages de même que
tous nos dans tous nos nouveaux
formulaires nous avons l'habitude de
voir des formulaires avec des oeufs
entre parenthèses vous êtes français
entend parenthèse mariés entre
parenthèses le aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
le ministère de l'intérieur comme unique
comme cela donc arrêtons de feu de
fantasmer sur ce point médian et
remarquons que le français peut être
parlé ou écrit de manière égalitaire
sans avoir d'ailleurs à inventer rien du
tout un puisque les ressources sont là
depuis des siècles depuis des séquences
effet de faire des accords autrement
qu'avec le masculin qui l'emportent sur
le féminin voyez c'est intéressant d
employer le mot fantasme brice couturier
vous vous dites effectivement vous dites
vous c'est pas un fantasme c'est une
sorte de révolution culturelle je
reprends vos termes un qu'on veut nous
imposer mais oui parce que ça ne vient
des états unis ça fait déjà longtemps
qu'aux états unis les néo-pros nantes ce
jeu si tu dis dire faen ferc sexy etc et
il y en a une trentaine enfin moment
facebook proposait une trentaine de
pronoms et vous savez que maintenant
chez dans les milieux aucun américain
chez les étudiants en particulier quand
on se présente on doit dire ces prénoms
dire que si vous reconnaissez dans le
fait que votre genre coïncide avec votre
anatomie vous êtes fille est un hymne
pour un garçon ichi et heures pour une
fille alors après il ya tous ceux qui ne
se reconnaissent plus dans cette
distinction et qui pensent que leur
anatomie ne les programmes pas à avoir
un genre particulier et évidemment
derrière cette introduction d'un mot
nouveau dans dix ionnaires il ya toute
l'idéologie où je remarque en passant
que le mohawk lui et maintenant usage
courant il est bizarrement il rentre pas
dans 10 ionnaires lui de parce que
évidemment le mot qu'il est là nous
lisons bon os il y circule pas mal le
morro qu'il est partout dans les médias
aujourd'hui alors que le miel n'est plus
le parent c'est à dire conscientiser
quoi voilà la mouche mais c'est comme ça
je traduis conscientiser mais le lui il
est d'usagé courant et ne rentre pas
dans ce dictionnaire je remarque que le
lyxor gras le lexicographe du larousse
aujourd'hui a déclaré c'était une erreur
de rentrée le miel le larousse ne le
prend pas il ya une meilleure provost il
lui faut le dire les choses c'est une
petite provocation que d'introduire des
pronoms nouveau pour faire rentrer dans
l'esprit des gens qu'on va et surtout ce
qui met alors le choc mais c'est l'idée
qu'on va transformer et rétablir une
égalité entre les sexes à partir d'un
tripatouillage de la langue il faut être
d'une naïveté celle ci en rééquilibrant
les salaires qu'on va équilibrer les
rapports entre les sexes c'est le genre
en changeant la langue que vous dites
est l'exemple américain avec un exemple
c'est la fille d'un ami qui est dans une
école de cinéma aux états unis est
effectivement été très surpris c'est une
française de ce que vous décrivez et
elle me dit c'est un témoignage alors
vous vous dire elle est forte dans ses
combats et ses manies mais ça m'a gêné
de devoir me définir finalement par
bonjean par ma sexualité est inscrit à
pas ce risque quand même
je crois qu'il est important quand même
de déplacer un peu le débat des états
unis il ya beaucoup d'autres langues et
de beaucoup d'autres pays qui qui
s'intéressent à la binarité dans la
langue qu'ils proposent d'autres prônent
on a en prenons en suédois qui est un
pronom neutre depuis des dizaines
d'années voilà il y avait sur la
question des évolutions du genre et des
identités de genre
les etats-unis' font partie des pays qui
sont touchés par cette transformation
mais quand on regarde par exemple à
l'état civil on a des introductions
d'identité de nouvelles identités donc
au trou ou neutres à l'état civil qui
n'ont pas forcément commencer par les
états unis qui vont commencer voilà par
exemple il y à il ya un an maintenant en
allemagne depuis quelques années voilà
donc donc donc je pense que ce focus sur
les etats-unis et peut-être pas la
meilleure idée olivier paccaud
je vous vouloir réagir dont je donne la
parole à l'isi
oui alors moi j'ai été un petit peu gêné
quand on nous a dit que en fait on
comprenait pas il s'agissait l'écriture
inclusive la politisation des questions
linguistiques c'est quelque chose qui
existe depuis très longtemps 15 139 lady
de villers cotterêts ou françois 1er
veut que ce soit le français qu'ils
soient utilisés pour les administratifs
ou les hussards noirs de la république
qui au début de la troisième république
vont bannir le patois de leur école mais
là il y avait un but très clair aussi
bien qu'à 139 que à la fin du 19e siècle
c'est que tout le monde se comprennent
mieux que les petits français que les
français se comprennent mieux là on est
dans une démarche est totalement
militante idéologues et très
objectivement
présenter la langue française comme un
outil ou un symbole de l'asservissement
de la femme de sa martyrisation où
va-t-on on est quand même au pays et à
la langue de l'amour du roman pour toi
ou autant de plus mon magnifier la femme
moi objectivement je ne peux pas
imaginer une fable de la fontaine un
poème de baudelaire une nouvelle de
maupassant un dialogue d'audiard un
dialogue de viard à l'écriture inclusive
c'est pas faux sears a de profondes sur
la fête et tout à l'heure allez vous
avez donné un témoignage de deux
sénateurs qui venaient voir l'étendue
puisez vous puissiez vous on est hors
sujet nous entendons tout comme on dit
on et off personne n'a jamais prononcé à
personne n'a jamais proposé monsieur et
on le répète sur tout cela partout où on
peut le dire depuis cinq ans de réécrire
les classiques ou de réécrire les choses
qui ont été signés par une personne moi
je suis la dure mère adorée les fables
de la fontaine et je veux
castrais chris yeh je vous rassure je ne
veux pas qu'elles soient réécrites et
les gens qui se sont amusés à réécrire
une fable de la fontaine ce ne sont pas
les personnes qui sont favorables à
l'écriture inclusive ce sont d'autres
personnes voyez le corbeau et l'accord
bella il ya toujours plus indique
cet absurde nous avons besoin pour lire
dire que vous êtes j'ai servi par
semaine un passant qui font des
caricatures et qui en est qui
entretiennent qui ont créé cette
polémique de toutes pièces depuis 4 ou 5
ans alors que notre problème il est il
est facile à résoudre nous pouvons
parler de manière absolument égalitaire
en recourant aux ressources
traditionnelles du français 6 à modifier
attendait il est dur à culoz il sait pas
dans les dossiers passent du français
c'est quelque chose que vous avez
inventé récemment bizarrement le point
médian ben c'est plus ce n'est pas sale
écriture égalitaire ce n'est pas ça
l'écriture non sexiste mauvaise foi
madame je suis désolé mais l'écrivain
que vous agi d'une réécriture et d'une
réforme de la langue il de réforme de la
langue est tournée par une minorité
rien entendu de ce que je vous ai dit le
point médian c'est une passe et une
passe et
c'était un rêve iations cette
abréviation de réforme de la langue qui
est prônée par une minorité active c'est
le problème que nous sommes à la réalité
lisez nos livres les élus ont évolué je
les juge des référés centres sociaux
nature du synthé autrefois c'était
l'état qui fixait la langue il le
faisait de manière autoritaire parce que
nous sommes dans une dans un état
autoritaire 7 l académie française qui
donnait le la et qu'ils disent est ce
que la langue devait être il y avait
près sûr il est temps aujourd'hui ce que
ce à quoi nous assistons c'est que des
minorités actives extrêmement
intolérante et est assez dissimulatrice
parce que elles donnent pas leur agenda
exactes sont en train d'essayer
d'attenté à la langue et d'imposer des
modifications qui déplaisent
fondamentalement à la majorité des
français et cette espèce ça provoque en
réaction comme ça pour vos cadeaux aux
états unis là
la montée des populismes être nos
centriste des racistes c'est qu'ils se
sentent attaqués dans l'identité même de
leur culture et on peut les comprendre
mais du coup ça donne des phénomènes
seymour est
d'accord annulant évolué oui elle
évoluera
par décret elle n'évolue pas en lui
imposant des choses qui ne sont pas dans
les usages elle évolue par l' usage tout
simplement c'est anonyme l'a dit lui
même dans les discours politiques ou des
discours public depuis le général de
plus que ce que vous nous dites c'est
que vous vous appelez une confusion
entre l'écriture exclusive et puis le
fameux point médian mais quand un
politique dit françaises français ou est
ce parce qu'il engage le sexisme du
langage a
dit madame la ministre et par
madame la maire ça l'écriture non
sexiste ce que vous appelez l'écriture
de succès c'est ça le langage non
sexiste il faudrait simplement mais ça
mais ça ne va pas plus loin et si vous
pensez même à adé même se prononcent
yale dont on parle si vous le mettez
dans une fois alors c'est certes c'est
un pro non non genre et c'est un nouveau
prônons qui mélangent ils et elles et
qui n'est pas genre et mais le pronom
nous n'est pas genre et le lion vous
n'etes pas gens comme ça ne fonctionne
pas dans une phrase si vous l'utilisez
dans une phrase vous êtes obligé ensuite
il ya il va être accordée avec un prono
avec un des noms avec des adjectifs à
l'égard que s'il y avait bien
écrit avec le voleur voilà de vous avez
pierre donc on est quand même
donc alors ça marche dans le cadre ça
m'a alors moi je dis mais madame dira
peut-être autre chose moi je dis ça
marche au pluriel dans le cadre de
l'écriture ou de l'écriture du langage
qui ne veut pas faire passer les femmes
a derrière la tapisserie et qui va dire
par exemple si on parle des étudiantes
et étudiants plutôt que de répéter les
étudiantes et les étudiants où elle est
il on va dire yelle mais on ne va jamais
masqué on va dire yale sont intelligents
points mais si on écrit ou et elles sont
intelligentes et intelligent si on parle
mais on ne va ce n'est pas fait pour
masquer ce entre autres sur les anime a
fait pour masquer le genre il faut
vraiment il ya un chiffon rouge là sur
lequel tout le monde l'a bien compris
qui est absurde sur le rôle politique de
la langue ou même la vision c'est une
vision du monde d'une certaine façon oui
tout à fait c'est une vision du monde et
est en fait de dire il me semble que se
prononce ou l'écriture non sexiste en
utilisant les formes masculines et les
formes féminines comme les étudiants et
les étudiantes ou en utilisant le point
médian de dire que cdd des injonctions
idéologique de la langue d injonction
politique c'est oublier que la langue
elle-même est quelque part à ces
politiques aussi et qu'elles
représentent des visions du monde et que
quand on a dit à une petite fille à
l'école pendant des années que le monde
était fait de boulanger de deux penseurs
ou
ou de chercheur et bien elle a plus de
mal potentiellement à se projeter dans
le social ont pu évoluer
réfléchi à ça et puis maintenant il y
maintenant analyser des charges alors
les articles vous verrez ils sont la
plupart des articles de la presse
d'aujourd'hui parle lorsqu'il parle
prétendument de population mixte en
parle au masculin on n'utilise que le
masculin l'histoire de famille fameux
masculin dit génériques dont les
psycholinguiste sable depuis 20 ans
qu'il n'est pas générique c'est à dire
qu'il qu'il suscite des représentations
d'hommes et bien c'est cesser de sela
partout c'est pas vrai que c'est mort on
s'est alors dit que c'est le plus grand
combat qui est devant nous pour les gens
qui veulent du langage non sexiste c'est
là c'est là la fin de ces sortir du
masculin générique arrêté parler des
français mais des français et les
françaises alors je reprends la main
j'essaye de ne pas trop vous interrompre
les uns et les autres mais comme il ya
beaucoup d'éléments et y en a un qui est
intéressant à venir grâce à audrey états
y avait eu des échanges au sénat cet
après midi sur ce thème à exactement
bonsoir audrey avec une passe d'armes
entre la sénatrice et maire laurence
garnier la milice déléguée chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et élisabeth morin et oui la polémique
s'invite jusque dans l'hémicycle alors
la sénatrice et les républicains
laurence garnier a commencé sa charge en
s'appuyant sur une interview d'elisabeth
moreno qui a dit que l'entrée du miel
dans le dictionnaire n'était pas si
choquant des propos qui tranchent sur le
papier avec ceux du ministre de
l'éducation nationale vous l'avez dit
jean michel blanquer vous l'avais déjà
dit mais je le rappelle on ne doit pas
triturer la langue française quels qu'en
soient les causes d'après lui la
sénatrice a donc interpellé la ministre
sur cette divergence de positions
polémiques d'après elle chacun a bien
compris que valider l'usagé prenons l
c'est validé l'écriture inclusive parce
qu'il faudrait pour nous explique ce
qu'il faut dire les baux où il ya les
belles donc il faudra écrire les deux
mais pour vous ça n'est pas si choquant
en réalité
vous aider rocchi sme et au lobby
vous segmenter la société à coups de
poing médian alors que votre rôle en
tant que ministre de la république c'est
de défendre ce qui nous rassemble
d'après elle valide et l'utilisation du
pronom yale s'est compliqué l'accès à la
lecture pour les personnes en situation
de handicap s'est ajouté des difficultés
à l'apprentissage de l'écriture et de la
lecture qu'en plus de la moitié des
élèves n'ont pas un niveau correct à
l'entrée en sixième ce sont ces propos
mais la ministre a tenu à se défendre a
précisé sa pensée dire que ce n'est pas
si choquant ce n'est pas valide et
l'utilisation du pronom yale defacto je
me suis exprimé sur le fait qu'il
n'était pas nécessaire et pour le coup
pardon de vous le dire mais je suis
totalement d'accord avec le ministre
jean michel blanc coeur pour dire que je
n'étais pas favorable à l'écriture
inclusive point à la ligne et je vous le
redis non je n'ai pas été choqué que le
petit robert fasse son travail et qu'il
met dans un dictionnaire un terme qui
est déjà dans la société voilà pour la
précision tout est dans le détail vous
l'aurez vu alors ce qu'on n'a pas
entendu dans ses extrêmes et qu'on a
entendu très fortement dans l'hémicycle
tout à l'heure c'est l'opposition entre
la partie droite de l'hémicycle et la
partie gauche au moment où la sénatrice
prenait la parole on avait la droite qui
l'encourageaient très bruyamment et en
face la gauche qui s'oppose est tout
aussi bruyamment donc on le voit le
sujet divise même sur les bancs du sénat
merci beaucoup audrey c'est vrai mathieu
c'est un marqueur politique aussi c'est
un marqueur politique parce que si vous
êtes content l'écriture inclusive ou
contre le promu yale vous êtes en
affreux réac ou un boomer ou ou un mâle
blanc patriarcal voilà et si vous êtes
pour vous êtes forcément ou au kiss
quelqu'un qui veut fracturé la nation
française qui a thing les gens à
identité au nom de controverse voilà on
est caricature contre caricature encore
une fois on n'arrive pas à réglementer
une langue on n'arrive pas à régenter
une langue bien que les pays
totalitaires qui le font la langue elle
évolue d'où ces noms qui vient du latin
il y avait trois joueurs dans la langue
latine je vous l'apprends pas où c'est
parker en a plus que deux chez nous
voilà c'est comme ça on ne changera pas
une langue avec des textes de loi ou une
commande avec un sénateur communiste qui
disait qu'il était content je ne
comprenais pas là l'écriture cette
question-là cette question de la
compréhension parce que la langue elle
est faite quand même pour communiquer
ses motifs disais tout à l'heure si les
gens ne n'arrive pas à se comprendre
communicant est bel usage combat et
mieux l'oeil elle disparaîtra peut-être
du dictionnaire l inverse si tout le
monde s'en saisit personnellement j'ai
je ne crois pas parce que je pense que
ça se fait pas d'un claquement de doigts
ça c'est pas en un à coup une un
changement de la langue ça ça prend du
temps pour qu'un usage qui fuse ça soit
la ccc à l'académie française de valider
l'évolution de la langue mais il ya six
femmes sur 34 membres aujourd'hui on a
fait le calcul c'est l'académie
française qui est masculine à 83%
peut-être un peu archaïque sa bouille
couture oui et je voudrais revenir ce
que vous disiez tantôt répondra magazine
non parce que c'est vrai gênante
l'académie française soit aussi
masculine et attendra j'attende 804
choisir sa part guy entre j'ai entendu
quelque chose qui me kim avec les je
suis en complet désaccord ça serait que
l'idée que ceux qui veulent attenter à
la langue bref les autistes sont la
gauche et que à droite sont ceux qui lui
résistent je suis absolument désaccord
je pense que les banques sont une toute
nouvelle gauche qui n'a rien à voir avec
ce qu'on entendait ici chez nous par la
gauche et c'est pour ça qu'on en
comprend pas la spécificité il s'agit
pas du retour des années 60 la lutte
anti flat luttes féministes et la lutte
antiraciste il s'agit pas d'un horizon
d'universalité et d'une égalité il
s'agit de demander des droits
particuliers il s'agit d'une cession
d'une partie de des minorités et d'une
politique agressive de la part de
certaines dsi norris contrat le poêlon
ce que vous appelez les hawks mais non
parce que regarder aux etats unis c'est
ce qui nous a menés donald trump tout de
même si si hillary clinton n'avait pas
cédé à la politique d identité qui est
qui qui qu'avec gangréné parti démocrate
américain trump n'aurait jamais été élu
et nous risquons la même chose ici
maintenant avec zemmour si nous conte
ici des minorités agissantes farfelu
continue à agresser le bon sens le sens
commun de celui qui a donc porté par la
majorité de nos concitoyens nous
risquons de provoquer ce genre de
bâclage c'est très dangereux il faut
arrêter ces folies mais on est à des
kilomètres du débat sur la langue et sur
le dictionnaire
moi je vois les engins je vois les
enjeux politiques vous vous que vous
voulez combien je pense que je vois les
enjeux politiques mon hôte notre souci
c'est de faire c'est d'accompagner la
légalité la progression de l'égalité
l'égalité ça ne croyez que ça va arriver
et changer de chance moi je ne propose
pas de changer la langue je propose de
jeu sur les gens ce débat que nous nous
débarrassions d' usage sexiste de la
langue qui ont été introduits à partir
du xviie siècle dans cette langue j'ai
fait suffisamment d'études monsieur j'ai
prouvé sa personne par mes études par
mes recherches personne ne remet en
cause mes recherches et wheels et j'en
fais une autre entre autres oui alors
suivez suivez le suivait le goût du vin
vous informez vous et je vais 7,7 sûr
c'est évident que la langue a été
masculiniser et nous devons la dea
masculiniser c'est la seule chose on a
pendant des heures les français
seulement de l'an maintenant depuis le
général de gaulle que vous devriez je
pense apprécié eh bien on parle du
français et des françaises aujourd'hui
on dit la ministre l'ambassadrice il ya
il a fallu quarante ans de lutte pour un
fou pour pour simplement revenir à du
français normal car parler de
l'ambassadrice c'est comme parler de
l'institutrice c'est du français normal
nous travaillons pour un français qu'ils
soient débarrassés des usages sexy ce
qu'on ya introduit et c'est pas trois
néologisme aux cinq néologisme qui vont
modifier la syntaxe du français qui vont
modifier le fonctionnement du français
et à et arrêtons de parler de l'amérique
ou de vous vous vous utilisez un jeu
c'est pas un
usage de l'anti américanisme qui n'a
rien à faire ni avec notre société ni
avec notre langue allez on va entendre
olivier paccaud là dessus des
masculiniser la langue française comme
anv aurait laissé à sa mort j'ai réagi
lassus g j'ai entendu donc madame dire
nous devons nous devons rider
masculiniser la ligne 23 ans s il faut
rééduquer en fait et j'ai l'impression
d'entendre
une forme de totalitarisme linguistique
on est dans un nez au totalitarisme
linguistique est comme ça a été dit sur
le plateau en fait c'est les français
qui font l'évolution de leur langue
c'est eux qui vont adopter ou pas votre
yale et objectivement mise à part dans
quelques assemblées syndicales est dans
un parti qui a pris 1 mais en parlant
olivier paradis les interrompt points
bien s olivier paquereau une seconde qu
est ce qui nous gêne en fait de
féminiser un nom métier je repose la
question qu'est ce qui vous gêne dans le
fait de féminiser un nom de métier
mais il se féminisera tout seul si je
vous répondrai quand il se féminisera
tout seul si la musicalité de la langue
l'encouragent mais c'est l'ambassadrice
tout le monde
d'ailleurs des gens l'utilisent c'est
pour ça qu'on de sa philosophie
philosophe est
d'ailleurs je précise que je dis je suis
précise que j'en ramène professeur uzi
professeurs c'est ce que oui on vous
présente le même cas non non vous avez
dit procès
se
disait voltaire c'est comme ça que
disaient nos ancêtres c'est comme ça
qu'on dit en français on dit chanteuse
danseuse et on dit professeurs ont dit
pas professeur pour une femme parce que
professeur précise et
novateur d'orthographe sur l'ordinateur
mais le souligne rouge bien sûr mais
vous savez ce sont des êtres humains qui
font les correcteurs qui font les les
correcteurs orthographiques alors et ils
vont changer alors on vous a interrompu
olivier paccaud alesi terminer votre
votre raisonnement
écoutez je sais plus exactement où j'en
étais mais la seule chose que je voulais
vraiment vous dire c'est que les
français dans leur usage courant ils ne
dépensent pas la langue certes il ne l'a
des gens ce pas et vous madame vous
voulez là des genres et tous je dis le
contraire de ville et josé et ça me gêne
des rigoles amené faut écouter sur la
sagesse le bons sens que l'on rencontre
dans la rue que l'on rencontre dans les
cafés que l'on rencontre dans les écoles
ils ne sont pas de votre côté je ne
pense pas vous réconcilier en 41 minutes
mes romans je vais faire avancer le
débat avec avec une image elle est tout
c'est tout près d'ici c'est le panthéon
avec sur la façade du panthéon cette
formule quand évidemment on est tous
passés devant fin quand on a le bonheur
de travailler dans ce quartier
magnifique aux grands hommes la patrie
reconnaissante
c'est un bon résumé de ce que vous
dénoncez dans votre livre william leno
ben oui on vient d'une société sexiste
on vient d'une société où les hommes
avaient plus de pouvoir de place de
valeur que les femmes et nous devons je
suis désolé de dire ça nous devons enfin
si nous sommes d'accord avec les
principes du pays dans lequel nous
vivons qui a déclaré que les femmes et
les hommes étaient égaux depuis 70 ans
nous devons réformer ce qui peut l'être
c'est pas facile toujours mais en tout
cas ce qui peut l'être doit être réformé
pour que nous allions vraiment vers
l'égalité que nous cessions de parler
voilà delà des droits de l'homme
aujourd'hui on ne devrait plus parler
des droits de l'homme aujourd'hui mais
des droits humains ou des droits des
humains où il ya plein de pays qui l'ont
fait et on sera bientôt les seuls à
garder cette cette terminologie qui a
été réel et est valable peut-être en son
temps mais qui ne correspond plus à
l'état de notre société est en tout cas
au désir déclaré de ce que nous voulons
faire aujourd'hui ensemble d'ailleurs
petit retour d'expérience en ce moment
dans le quartier devant le panthéon il
ya pas mal de mise en place de travaux
pour la cérémonie d'entrée de joséphine
baker au panthéon sera le 30 novembre
elle deviendra seulement la cinquième
femme et voilà anisé après marie curie
geneviève anthonioz de gaulle germaine
tillon et simone veil ça progresse mais
lentement qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
d'autre au delà de la langue les lounge
file peut-être rebaptiser les rues de
certaines villes est ce que vous y êtes
favorable donner plus de place aux
femmes dans nos villes je crois que ça
se fait pas ça se fait
voilà je sens qu'il ya des par exemple
simone de beauvoir a eu une plateforme
si c'est ça ou
donc ça se fait moi ce qui m'interroge
quand même c'est cette cette polémique
épidermique autour de se prononcer
demain de l'entraînement d'un usage en
fait dans le robert d'un usage certes
minoritaire mais qui existe et je
m'interroge en fait sur pourquoi est-ce
que ça a déclenché autant autant de
ballades eu de réaction épidermique et
donc on peut se demander en fait si
c'est pas quelque part le fait de
troubles et la binarité ou de d'avoir
quelque chose de keane qui peut nous
nous faire comment nous faire envisager
le monde autrement que de constitué
essentiellement d'hommes et de femmes
qui va là est-ce que c'est pas ce
trouble l'acquis arrêt qui a provoqué
toutes ces réactions je suis président
revient en jeu politique derrière si je
vais essayer de faire ça sans caricature
emilia une approche universaliste qui
était plutôt la tradition française et
qui au nom de l'universalisme et qui
considérait que tous le monde étaient
égaux
il ya certains qui sont 110 et qui sont
aujourd'hui plus différentialiste vous
êtes sympas on est tous égaux sauf que
il y en a qui sont moins égaux que
d'autres et qui son invisibilité parce
que les plus égaux cdm des hommes blancs
dans ce groupe universaliste riz est
donc une autre approche qui est en train
de monter j'essaie de vous corriger mais
qui est plus différentialiste où on
reconnaît les différences ou d'allah je
sais pas comment la qualifier mais on
doit pouvoir affirmer son identité et la
faire reconnaître et que ces deux ces
deux tendances la s'entrechoquent
sans doute parce que ça crée des
frictions ça fait peur aux uns et parce
qu'il ya un agenda politique les des uns
et des autres mais je trouve que c'est
une version du débat m on peut aussi
voir ses revendications notamment les
revendications d'écriture non sexiste et
plein d'autres revendications politiques
comme des revendications d'égalité avant
d'être des revendications de
reconnaissance d'identités sociaux
l'égalité se font universal est en fait
aussi potentiellement oui je suis au
final le au final sans doute peut-être
lemay l'universalisme ya le vrai il faut
le vrai universalisme il doit faire avec
les différences il doit reconnaître
l'égalité de tous le monde dans les
différences et quand on quand on pense
je sais pas moi oui au grand homme là
c'est pas l'universalisme peut-être
qu'on a pensé à un moment je
n'ai pas lancé sanglante et on s'est
elle et d'universalisme ça n'en est pas
c'était un faux universalis donc nous
travaillons moi en tout cas je travaille
à réaliser un véritable universalisme
qui tireront donc mais vous avez vous
cette approche différentiel des fruits
aussi une approche identitaire
une forme d'assignation à résidence
absolument genre mais c'est un autre
actualité en fonction des heures de
cours en fonction de celui du débat mais
vous voyez bien que c'est ce que j'ai
dit comme ça c'est pas seulement sur le
pronom ces deux visions là qui
s'entrechoquent sur l'universalisme mais
vous ne pouvez rien faire un strip avec
l'écriture égalité avec le différentiel
ça n'a rien à faire le français il
connaît le français l'espagnol l'italien
les longues romaine connaissent le genre
masculin et le genre féminin et elle se
débrouille avec ça et elles doivent se
débrouiller avec un créneau reste dans
ce bon le marianne vos seins c'est un
modèle universaliste n'a rien à faire à
l'exclusion curieux c'est l'introduction
en france une logique qui fait des
identités minoritaire des opprimés de
nature et qui leur donne une stature
politique qui rentre on avait un débat
droite gauche c'était un débat
relativement intéressant et organisé
quand on rentre dans un débat vous avez
des minorités qui entraîne d'ailleurs
enregistre énormément de conflits mutuel
parce que l'idée d'un terreau sexualité
en été ça marche pas vous arrivez dans
un autre système politique qui est celui
de la lutte des minorités contre une
majorité écrit beaucoup et pardon nous
interrompt parce que le temps est
vraiment écoulée et je voudrais citer
quand même vos livres en finir avec
l'omc chronique d'une imposture cette
audition x notre is no ise émancipation
par le neutre les liens qui libèrent et
hockey millénium seul en quête d'un baby
boomer sur les mythes de la génération
web chez l'observatoire de